we get puppy wuppy it's whoopee oh here
we go hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome back to Sophie's
curse
I've actually got buddy in the room here
with me you can't see her but she's
breathing into the microphone right now
aren't you you sweet little pup
and she's gonna keep me safe through
this horrible nightmare of everything
that's going wrong in this house so I
was trying to think about how to do
better at this game and that didn't work
out very well because my brain is not
very good the think doing didn't that
right puppy Oh
chicas running away cuz she thinks I'm
yelling at her probably she's not used
to me talking so loudly to no one in
particular I mean I'm talking to you
guys but er I might as well be talking
to no one
goddammit I forgotten where the buttons
are where you push things to go places
darush darn it I'm trying to find where
the safe room is thank you chica she
brought me a bone she brought me a bone
chica you want to say hi oh here we go
yeah chica say hi hello wave your paw
hello hi chica who do good puppy
say hi to the audience okay never mind
then all right chicas good I better put
sigue down cuz she doesn't seem to like
that very much
oh no she's fine she gains okay I know
it's a scary game Oh Booga oh she's
gonna be feet oh she's so cute
anyway back to this so I was trying to
think of how best to do this game and I
couldn't come up with a strategy and I
was trying to read comments but most of
the comments in the last video were just
people talking about the jump scares
where they were so that they they could
avoid them what's the point of watching
a horror game if you're gonna just avoid
all that the jump scares that was it
right button I was trying to click
somewhere else and it wasn't working
okay so the save point is at a oddly
enough that's good because that means
that I'm near the save point at the
bottom and I don't have to go up sleep
with grandma grandpa grandma ha it's
both it's bulls bursting one bunny
Murphy
take I got
left okay anyway oh that doesn't sound
good
huh all right hello baby
[ __ ] rabbit now that God dares I wasn't
trying to go upstairs I'll sign your
deck to the same point can I go back to
the freakin save point thank you I don't
know what happened but this is under
guard okay so the save point is here I
know that for a fact and I know that I'm
supposed to be listening out for a
creepy noise of some sort whenever I'm
charging these things and I'm supposed
to stop immediately what it's not
incredibly obvious oh my god she could
just rubbage by my I think that might
have been the creepy noise oh I heard
like a UH something crying or I don't
like it I don't like it much at all oh
well it's are you supposed to do what
was I supposed to the quick guide Sophie
can be pretty mean I'm aware of that I'm
aware so I guess if Sophie appears in
front of me like that I need to figure
out a better way to oh my god I'm sorry
Oh chica be God I'm so sorry chica don't
run away
I'm sorry I accidently I I've crossed my
legs sometimes on the sitting down I
think I kicked her in the face
I'm sorry chica bika oh okay oh man it's
all the way up with grandpa again I
never feel safe when I'm standing
outside of grandpa's door staring in all
creepily in fact I don't know how
grandpa
feels safe I mean I'm pretty sure this
isn't exactly my grandpa yeah whatever
can I work out gonna work out fine what
what would happen if tea Chico is with
me in this environment grandpa grandpa
grandpa I hear a strange noise grandpa
oh okay
do ah Frick I need to put up the guides
for the buttons how do I put them back
up how do I put him back up I want to
put up my dukes so I can at least defend
against this horrible ghost I gotta get
to at least 10:00 a.m. p.m. right
I don't know god damn it why is it
always up with grandpa
I ruined my one opportunity to have my
safe point by the kitchen with all the
beer not that I can drink beer anymore
because I died my heart would explode
apparently to get a crank this yank that
sounds like a creepy noise I'd prana I'm
gonna go up to the safe point because
apparently that's where I'm safe case my
Lobby was in there chica what are you
doing Gigi you do grandpa is that you
grandpa
might not have been grandpa that might
have been something else grandpa was a
Honan grandpa doing something under the
covers and I don't want to be a part of
yeah man the charges are all going down
pretty quickly after that god damn it
it's like after a few minutes the
charges all start dropping rapidly I
need to listen for
any sort of creepy noises but everything
sounds creepy what do they try to pull
this whole house is filled with creeps
pen squeaks and Miki markiplier zat
don't wanna be oh god oh god oh god oh
god oh god okay haha well that I'm on it
hello Evan
I'm not missing soon oh gotta get my
zone that's all the way it was grandpa
poor Gado Gado Gado Goethe Goethe girl
okay I guess we're fine then okay so
what was the point of that why did that
all happen laughs I'm not that way that
way my safe zone isn't here it's
upstairs
I'm just gone that would be nice yeah
Sophie you're such a meanie puss you're
such a Fuji [ __ ] I didn't good I'm
assuming the whimpering might be me yeah
I don't know I don't know why I don't
know why anything's happening yeah I
don't understand
chica what are you doing take a help
help chica help hope Teager help help
Tigger help Teager not going well
oh there you are I thought you came
around the side of me she came in
between my legs all right I got one hand
petting chica right now everything's
gonna be a-okay I'm Orion now are in I
just need to get another hour under my
bar I'm in my safe zone I'm in my safe
zone I'm in my safe home with grandpa I
got you right here
nothing at army nothing can harm me in
my safe point okay Oh
chicas licking my foot ah that's
slightly disturbing chica I appreciate
the sentiment but it's kind of weird oh
man come on I was already clicking
forward god damn it I'm sorry chica
you're okay Oh uh-huh
god damn and I can get through this I
can do this I just need to not be I
guess I need to stop you know I need
like pause before I go anywhere because
if I click forward when she's in front
of me I'm just gonna die there's no two
ways around it I'm just gonna die right
chica I don't want to die
chica save me chica save me
Namie chika I just got I just got hot
dog breath on my crotch right now and no
it's not a good time so like every time
that I move I need to like pause for
just a hot second before I click forward
because it's just gonna end in my desk
okay calm and collected calm and
collected is the name of the game I
don't know what that was
oh is that grandpa probably yeah just
stop for a hot second okay then move why
does that keep happening how many things
can break in this goddamn house how many
things can explode how many times can I
die over and over again in the same
futile manner not not futile futile
futile
ha-ah arrrgh Ararat d why is there an
arrow or in my safe zone this isn't
appropriate for me okay don't panic just
calm okay go forward
okay here we go air or on on code is
4278 he's all oh well I didn't do that I
didn't do that I mean this may save
that's not my safe zone my sonís of
tears of tears by D by D's nuts
I got damnit off there was no [ __ ] ahh
that was not okay that was not okay but
it's alright because we're gonna survive
this so long as we don't panic like a
goober that I am I'm a hundred percent
authentic goober Ness still up bye
grandpa
of course cuz that never changes I was
down by a and then it's completely gone
every time you responses by grandpa okay
but it's fine it's fine
oh go the other way okay got it okay so
I can I'm pretty sure I can just stay in
one spot gotta go save some ah so I
don't have to be moving around like a
maniac all the time
I don't I can't stay generally oh no not
that not that nothing about that damn it
I can't generally stay in one spot
ah she could don't lick my leg she gets
out that she go ah jjigae not helping
not opening chica chica stop stop do you
digger later what of what of what a
meanie person what a mean person I'm
gonna get through this I'm gonna get
through this no matter what it's time to
focus it's time to focus all of my
energy into solving this crisis and
chica if you could stop distracting me
it'd be delightful
so what happens if I just stay here for
a little bit check my safe zone ah my
safe zones an a I like that okay moving
out moving out a safe zone is that a
though that's a little awkward because
she was kind of there okay whatever
it's fine by me okay see everything is
fine so now it's just like if if it just
so happens that she appears when you
click to move and that's totally
possible you just died yeah that's not
fair
or maybe that's not how it works but
that's how I I seemed it seems to work
that way walk in there where we go back
day ah yeah ah okay all right
crazies over oh okay
down down down down down down down down
down down down oh whoa I'm far away from
a far away okay it's fine though it's
fine it's fine it's fine - fine
everything's fine okay
you're the only dangerous part is when
you're moving
okay safe zone all right right away huh
okay
okay everything is okay in the safe zone
ELISA changed over at nine o'clock which
is always a possibility what it can do
okay I'm just gonna check to make sure
that it hasn't changed anything cuz I
made it to nine yep still still right
there that's good
huh well [ __ ] that's how I say so come
on oh god oh god oh god dammit Garrett
this is a panic it's it's a panicked
action
I better be moving I better be moving I
better be moving I better be moving I'm
moving I'm moving to move it I'm okay
I'm okay I'm okay I'm okay everything's
fine everything's a hundred percent aoki
things 100 percent Aoki
oh that was oh man what a douche what
the [ __ ] that's so stupid it's too ah
goddamnit the stupid [ __ ] not dead yet I
mean I have a funny feeling that death
is gonna be approaching but I'm not dead
yet
everything's fine my character seems to
be doing a lot of deep breathing yoga
which is the most important thing to be
doing when you're in a house with a
haunted negative of dying Grandpop's
tears yes of course don't sprint out the
front door and call the cops that would
be the silliest thing to do with such a
silly Bailey and everything's fine
that's so weird
that is weird maybe I was causing
problems because I who was running
around like an idiot well I don't know
where she was I didn't even see her but
I'm gonna go I did not see her it's okay
everything's fine everything's fine
things cool calm and collected just like
that
everything's back to normal
he's gonna gig
okay okay going up see grandpa grandpa
grandpa huh ah is that just because I
cannot let them all go offline I
literally can't let them go offline or
else I'll just die no matter what I
think that's what that was
okay so now we've learned that we can
move forward huh okay
still with Grandpa of course of course
our grandpa
just gotta be cool and calm and
collected cool and calm and collected
cool in calm and collected and not let
anything run out of power ever cuz
that's what kills you and then
everything else kills you
and then just standing around kills ya
and then looking Sophie in the face
kills you just like this I love it there
yeah I love it that a tornado siren goes
off every time she's around hopefully
that would alert everyone in the nearby
area
doughboys the giant monster lady not
giant she's not very big
cheeky Becky chica chica come save me
she could come save me save me chica
chica nope there she is up there's
that's dama crotch thanks chica yeah
get this
yeah okay grandpa spine grandpa's a-okay
don't need to check on grandpa
okay oh that's not good okay going
upstairs Jay I got a chicken grandpa
grandpa honey's my dungeon grandpa needs
help going to the bathroom grandpa's
doing it
okay badly I think I'm just starting to
get the hang of this I think I'm
starting to get the hang of this it's
not unfair it was unfair of me to say
that it was unfair but it seems to be it
seems to be understandable there's a
method to the madness it's not you know
it's kind of like you know when I
started playing five nights at freddys
you know it seemed like everything was
random and sporadic but there's a
pattern there is method to the madness
there is a method to the madness still
with Grandpa nice and also it seems like
once you charge him up to maximum they
kind of stay there for a little bit so
you want whenever you charge him you
want to make sure that they go all the
way up grandpa needs my attention
oh my god oh that needs my attention
more than that here
oh god what a complicated system why is
this even this way we'll get a [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] there we go got it
nothing's blown up everything's okay oh
and collected
all and collected
look before you leap whoa okay good
thing I'm here right where I need to be
look before you leap that's the main
lesson of this one look before you leap
look before you leap look before you
leap
leap look before you leap look before
you leap everybody never has a lesson by
mordru then right now I'm turning into
grandpa grandpa got to his ripe old age
because he looked before you I look
before he left
my great great hurry okay we're fine
everything's fine
Oh everything's fine looks a-okay only
got a few more seconds to go
everything's a-okay
okay damn it I meant to charge up
grandma
okay
be careful look before you leap
leave bleep look look leaving
look I'm leave looking ugly looking a
left look I look left I look left look
look left leg look left look left look
over your lip okay I think I ain't just
camp here until the time runs out I'm
pretty sure I can do that
hurry up hurry up hurry up hurry up 9:55
we're fine ray okay we're good to go
we're a okay I think it's fine
everything is awesome everything is cool
when you're part of the team Oh God
rolling right along but I'm not ready
for this okay let's see how quickly I
die now probably very quickly as long as
I look before I leap everything shall be
okay oh [ __ ] Reba Reba sorry rubble Oh
God
grandpa grandpa Oh God should I check on
grandpa Oh
whoa whoa grandpa I heard noises were
you dreaming loudly grandpa
like your grandpa
if you scream pop Oh I think the same
boy was here I'm not sure okay
chitty-chitty know what having to kiddie
grandpa what did you did a kitty okay I
asked Lee didn't expect to make it this
far I thought that I thought the death
was going to approach very quickly it
apparently is just a sound the symphony
of death the death surrounds to be okay
symphony of death symphony of death but
symphony of death is okay as long as I'm
alive so long as I'm in the eye of the
tornado of death in dismay I think I'll
be okay this is gonna be hard
how am I gonna be able to get down there
fix it before all the other ones go out
of power
good question mark Inu let's try it
[ __ ] who's gonna be tight oh crap
quickly quickly quickly quickly
the opposite of quickly is what I'm
doing [ __ ] come on okay okay get it get
it okay we're fine good Jesus
shut up up there I mean do whatever you
want grandpa but just do it quietly Oh
gonna be tight
kitty yeah oh god damn it damn it man I
was just about to get there hope it's
still a I didn't check better be a if d
is like okay that's good if he was gonna
put D at a crisis point right then and
there I was going to be royally pissed
royally pissed
ooh I didn't look before I leap going
down to Grandpa see it's they're like oh
they're like oh okay nevermind then I
was wondering if there were like 13
other stories above us and there's an
insane asylum literally the insane
asylum from outlast is our upstairs
neighbor and they are having one hell of
a time that does kind of sound like
Chris Traeger
from outlast doing his thing okay never
mind then alright we're just gonna go
back to a bad day everything's okay
we're gonna make through this checkpoint
then we're gonna quit cuz I've had
enough chica chica I'm almost done
chica come on chica chica chica chica
chica chica chica oweme oweme [ __ ]
[ __ ] home oh there you are Oh who's a
cute puppy who's in adorable pups whoops
didn't mean to do that I think it's
gonna be okay
who's an adorable pup cheer up G oh I
think I got this I think I got it I
think we're okay I think it's gonna be
okay
okay yeah yeah yeah oh come on time go
well faster yeah okay so that's all I'm
gonna do for now I'm gonna just let
myself die in horrible monstrous ways
Savin enough of this thank you everybody
so much for watching I'll get back to
this game and I should be able to finish
it all in one more episode if I'm as
good as I think I am now but I don't
know what curve balls is gonna throw at
me towards the later night so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye
so stay get out ah you guys suck you're
ruining all let me go sister ever came
out and told me that I needed to wake up
in order breakfast